but uh we were talking about january 6 i
want to jump to this story and i want to
give a shout out right away to uh tim
cast good friend alexandria
ocasio-cortez
uh we have this tweet here
she said remember how they were taught
there was tons of footage and evidence
of officers and others inside on january
6 supporting insurrectionists but then
everyone decided it was too politically
risky to investigate thoroughly so they
brushed under the rug and now we still
have no idea who or what is safe
i agree with aoc on this i want to play
you this video
that there were actual officers working
with this and we never got to the bottom
of that and we never got any answers
about that and then to this day we're
just supposed to pretend that that never
happened
i have no idea what happened to the
people on the inside who were very
clearly sympathetic with what was going
on and opening the doors wide open for
that and where i'm supposed to sit here
and
just right there yep opening the doors
pretend like none of that ever happened
and then right afterwards you have a
massive you know you just have this idea
that throwing money at that problem is
going to make it go away we could burn
somebody accountability and so this is
this is where these things are breaking
down we're not safe and it's not just
about members of congress not being safe
the staff workers aren't safe the
janitors aren't safe like we need to get
to the bottom of this so that's all i
gotta say what about it thank you
congresswoman i am i i am uh thoroughly
annoyed by the guy who just keeps
yelling antifa over and over again as
someone who's like been more critical of
antifa than many people who've spoken
out and criticized them from the get-go
starting with occupy wall street when we
were on the ground me and my friends and
the black black extremists were
attacking us and then eventually they
adopted the name antifa they were just
the black black extremists the same
people that we know their names many of
them
and uh aoc
is
enthusiastically saying there were cops
who opened the doors
from the inside she never says the cops
opened the door says there were cops
inside people on the inside opened the
doors she doesn't make the direct
statement sure
was opening the door the insinuation is
that there were there was law
enforcement inside she's saying she
doesn't feel safe because she doesn't
know what happened to those people who
were inside
whoever they were
she's right
the american people need to know there
were people inside who opened the doors
can can we can we blast that message out
there can we stop for one second and say
look i get aoc doesn't care about ante
for riots or anything like that fine but
the one thing we do agree on we want an
investigation into the people who opened
the doors from the inside who are they
why and what does that mean for those
being criminally charged aoc is on board
why are people screaming at her yeah
there one guy got let out of solitary i
don't know if he was in solitary led out
of jail because the judge said well a
police officer waved you in you're not
liable for trespassing or whatever they
let them go and she was talking about
the safety of congress of those in
congress right what did she have to say
about um supreme court's the supreme
court justices and expanded security she
said what is poor him or something like
that poor guy yeah she's a hypocrite
yeah but you know what
this is the thing there are people in a
cult a cult leader just came out and
said we have this problem and i'm like
we got an invoice
now we can go to each and every one not
now i can go to every one of these
co-members and be like well look i agree
with aoc you know aoc wants an
investigation into these cops and the
people who open the doors from the
inside she is right about that there she
is hands down she's not wrong either
that they're not safe it's not a safe
environment to centralize your
government anymore you don't need to
have everybody sitting inside of one
building that can be surrounded like
it's just too not today it doesn't make
i don't know i'm with her man i want to
i think i don't think it's as big a deal
as you think so you think it is i you
know one of the things we said back on
january 6 was we mocked the people who
tried breaking their way in saying
why do you do you think that standing in
a building grants you political power
it's not the 1600s
so
even if they're in one building like
it's not going to disrupt to a great
degree at least the the us government
i'm more intrigued by the fact that she
was like what are we just going to throw
more money at this problem and hope that
solves it like you vote for big spending
all the time what are you talking about
you think this works for everything else
but not this i i'm looking at a
priorities list right you got aoc has
been hypocritical in terms of what
happened with the violent riots there
what happened with the riots the rest of
the country she supported people being
harassed so she gets uh alex stein yells
at her big booty latina and for the most
part i think it's a non-story and it's
it's it's stupid anyway distraction you
know so but i'm i'm more upset that the
media is using it to distract so it is
kind of dumb
but
she gets harassed and then she's like i
was gonna deck him oh i can't believe he
would say that to me but then brett
kavanaugh gets harassed and she doesn't
care one bit but i look at that and i'm
like okay there's priorities i will
criticize her for that but then she
comes out and she hits a 10 out of 10
grand slam out of the park people open
the door from the inside i want an
investigation i'm like bingo there it is
that's what we want to hear right steve
bannon said something similar this is uh
months and months ago maybe even a year
ago or whatever he was like i want an
investigation he's like i i want a
hearing let's get an investigation to
exactly what happened on january 6 and
i'm like oh well all right okay because
the idea is a legitimate
investigation why were there cops
standing around as people pleaded for
them to intervene you see the video the
guy goes to the cops what are you doing
please stop this the cops just do don't
move why weren't there enough cops there
where was the national guard
why were people opening the door from
the inside
those questions need to be answered one
guy got acquitted of all charges because
the judge saw a video of cops waving
them in
that legit waving them in
we need answers
i play a lot of video games crusader
kings if you can get your enemy
committing a petty crime you can throw
him in prison
and strip him of all his all his land
and all his titles and erase him from
well it's like a petty crime in grand
theft auto you guys ever played gta
mm-hmm you play you you have played it
yeah uh ian
grant you still love it what you do is
you
in the video game if you go up to a
random person and attack them
and then they fight back and you run to
a police car the police will start
brutally beating the person who is
attacking you so and i'm talking about
trick him i'm talking about political
like like your own subordinates like if
you're king and it's your duke and you
don't like him and you catch him doing
some slander or something you can throw
him in yeah if someone if someone lets
him in if you open the door so that he
can commit a crime you can throw that
guy in prison like
there's a reason to let people commit
crimes for authorities sometimes because
then you got them and i want to know if
that's what they did take a look
oh sorry no i was just i think it might
have been you guys last night on on on
the show uh
with libby and kurt but somebody raised
the question you know why is there only
select footage being released like
release everything like let's just
make it make it all public take a look
at this story from the daily mail secret
service deleted texts from january 5th
and 6th homeland security's inspector
general reveals amid its internal probe
why yeah they say many texts between the
u.s secret service were deleted after
the watchdog made a request for
electronic communications the letter
states yo
the right seems to think that if we get
a real investigation it'll prove that
feds were involved
the left seems to think it'll prove that
trump orchestrated the whole but i think
i don't care one way or the other alex
is insulin i think she's the kind of
mind that's like if we get evidence that
the cops let people in and and incited
this then we've got innocent people in
prison and this is
beyond effed and and
a lot of people in the establishment of
that were the case wouldn't want her to
turn like that they want those people
insulated thinking that they were just
attacked by a mob right because it's
convenient i think regardless of what
the the end result is
if police opened the doors and that and
as a fact they did there are peop cops
who opened the door and said i don't
agree with it but i respect it they said
that to those two people there's
a cop waving at people waving them to
come in
they've argued oh no the cop was waving
at uh um uh other cops
it's like i don't know where care
there's a video of them fanning at the
trump supporters who then started
walking in there are people movies
pictures of yes yeah they're taking
selfies yeah if that was part of the
january 6th hearings which is not
the american people would be here would
be would be feeling some they'd be
feeling very different about what
happened instead i'm hearing about how
people saw my clip posted by jamie
raskin out of context and they don't
know or care what i actually said the
smear is intentional what they're doing
is intentional they are lying and
manipulating now
the good news for us is that we're part
of a new sect of media where we have
massive key demo viewership most people
who watch this are like 30 we get 18 to
54 we get it very very well but you have
millions who are watching cnn msnbc and
fox news
and fox news not the worst not all that
great
that's where the old people are and so
they believe all the nonsense now the
funny thing is whenever the january
january 6 hearings are on fox news his
ratings tank so they just like try not
to do it because nobody wants to watch
that stuff
manipulation and lies
do we know what the actual ratings have
been for the january six hearings
because i see a lot of like like
whenever i'm doing research for what
we're covering you still get a lot of
like that stuff like deadline
uh hollywood reporter they're covering
it because it's technically part of the
the
media stream right they're high but low
okay like they they got like tens of
millions of viewers across the board but
it's relatively low compared to every
other hearing people really are tuning
out from this stuff why
the average person does not like joe
biden this is the funny thing with joe
biden at a hitting record low approval
ratings to down to like 37.7
i've said it before the opportunity
there two-thirds of this country doesn't
like the guy okay make fun of him it's a
big market share
but they don't
you'd think every single person would be
like look
if i want votes
bet against biden everybody hates him
instead they're not doing it they're
passively in behind the scenes being
like we need to get somebody else
but where are the late night hosts to be
like ladies and gentlemen who watch this
show i know you all hate joe biden
because even democrats don't want him to
run but for some reason they just keep
propping him up i thought watching
colbert really go at kamala harris on
that interview it was like a year ago or
something he's like when you were
running against joe biden you said
horrible stuff it was a
debate
he's like so what it's okay to lie if
it's a debate but steve he hasn't like
come out and be like i cannot stand that
woman she lied yeah she
put
like i want to see him honest about his
feelings for kamala harris well i want
to know what happened to kamala because
it seems like when she was running
against him she was in a chad felix
screen i follow him on twitter i love
his tweets he's very smart um but he he
tweeted the other day this this point
basically which was you know we we saw a
woman who was so well spoken she was uh
you know she would cut your throat you
know and she and now her sentences don't
even make sense it's just strange she
seems so targeted and so
fearless and and it's just strange to
see what's happened to her like it's
like every step she's about to fall it
feels like she's about to fall into lava
is what it looks like she's so nervous
to say the wrong thing that she just
says he's ridiculous circular
circular yeah yeah that's right that is
interesting i hadn't thought about that
but you're right yeah she was a
prosecutor she was an ambitious woman i
don't have a high opinion of ambitious
women but they get stuff done you know i
always thought of her as like somebody
who really speaks a lot in like
declarative sentences right right it's
like i'm going to cut to the chase this
is the point
and now it's
skirt around in circles and say nothing
and it's very weird to see it she's
expected to live a lie now because she
really didn't like joe biden and was
very overt about that during the debates
and now she's got to pretend like it so
it's making when you live a lie people
become crazy nervous wrecks i mean
that's that's to me it seems like it's
the only explanation i mean but you know
if if if they don't run biden
i mean what is she doing for her
political future at this point if she
can't even
make a sentence
i don't i don't get it yeah there's no
way she got to where she is today by
using those weird auto-correct
predictive text sentence style of
speaking she used to be very like i feel
like she was evil in the way she worked
but she worked she worked she got stuff
done she made people you know work for
free she enslaved people right but she
did all of these things competently
whatever you thought of what she did and
now she's like i think you're right i
think she's terrified and you're right
she's not doing anything for her
political future all she's doing is
picking fights with people in the white
house like people it's an incredibly
toxic workplace like working with an
ambitious like lady like that is very
toxic there it becomes a very
um it becomes an entangling battle of
wills where they feel like they're being
slighted over every little thing and
it's like how are you supposed to make
progress with that and there's no way
for a lady like that to do to for
example get into office nobody wants her
for president she i believe she's far
less like uh she's far less liked even
even joe biden and that's way less like
than donald trump was at this point yeah
she does give off like incredibly
nervous energy yeah like somebody who
starts talking but forgets what they're
about to say and has to kind of make it
up as they go yeah but you know what i
mean yeah i know and yeah it's well it's
like that michael scott quote sometimes
i start a sentence yeah i forget where
i'm going
keep
all of that sounds like that when she's
talking like when she does the circular
logic that's what it sounds like yeah no
i i completely agree it's gotta be like
psychologically debasing to know that
you were selected for your
office because of the color of your skin
right like if they're like we need a guy
with long hair
ian you can do it like i'd be like well
i guess that blows
i do meet the requirements yes thanks
yeah well that's kind of how i feel
about their press secretary she was
literally chosen because of her skin
color and her sexual orientation
grading can i read some inspirational
quotes for you guys find it yes oh from
harris yes let's do it
my favorite we must together work
together to see where we are where we
are headed where we are going and our
vision for where we should be but also
see it as a moment to yes
together address the challenges and to
work on the opportunities that are
presented by this moment
here's another one what else do we know
about this population 18 through 24 they
are stupid i remember that
inspiring ukraine is a country in europe
it exists exists next to another country
called russia
russia is a bigger country russia is a
powerful country russia decided to
invade a smaller country called ukraine
so basically that's wrong she's reading
children's books
she's an auto text robot
it's like chat bots are more more
inspiring this is my favorite quote from
her it is time for us to do what we have
been doing and that time is every day
i mean it could be worse she didn't say
end quote repeat the line that's true
that's a good point
what is what is which is worse yeah
it's pretty bad yeah
we all watched the television coverage
just yesterday that's on top of
everything else that we know and don't
know yet based on what we've just been
able to see and because we've seen it or
not doesn't mean it hasn't happened oh
what
what
predictive text generator
oh my gosh it's time for us to do what
we've been doing and that time is every
day i'm so inspired oh man that's
amazing deep thoughts
is there just something going around
this white house that makes people lose
their ability to communicate is that
just the leftism is it just nervous
energy i i actually like
like she even had her posture even seems
like her shoulders are super tense yeah
i mean like she doesn't seem like she's
actually ready for any of her public
interactions what we must do she's kind
of looking down a lot too
what we must do yes
today with these times is do what we've
done
when we need you you really had me for a
second
when we are
in times like now yes
i am inspired those are fun to say
well it's fun because everyone's
listening to you and they're looking at
you and you know you're not saying
anything
and so it's just like keep looking
let's go with it
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8pm eastern time super
chat we'll even answer some of your
questions if you want to check out the
after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you